we all know that the tube map distorts
reality
usually that's useful but not always i'm
going to take the map's route from
lancaster gate to paddington
and i'm just going to walk above ground
i have to go down a lift waste to
platform catch the train two stops get
off the train take a long walk through a
station up some stairs waste another
platform catch another train two stops
and then walk through the bowels of
paddington station
it takes 15 minutes for me to get there
as you can see on the above ground map
tom has taken a massive detour when in
reality
the two stations are just around the
corner from my perspective
i just took a pleasant five-minute walk
through the streets of london it didn't
cost me anything
and i even had enough time at paddington
station to get a cup of tea
and really freak out tom oh i genuinely
thought i'd won that
there are more subtle lies on the
underground too bank station gets a
flood of commuters going one way in the
morning and the other way in the evening
so the signs change depending on the
time of day according to the bbc series
the tube at times staff will even root
commuters deliberately around a very
long detour
this will slow them down and prevent a
dangerous crush
without making anyone angry but it
doesn't explain king's cross
from the victoria line i'll follow the
signs to
trains and i'll do the smart thing i'm
going to head straight to the low-key
houston road exit while matt uses
insider knowledge i have to walk along
the crowded platform up a set of stairs
through a series of rather long tunnels
that just keep going
through the new northern ticket hall
through king's cross itself before
finally meeting matt after five minutes
i've got to start taking the short
routes why did i get there first
because all i had to do was go up an
escalator pop outside for a minute
and there i am at the mainline entrance
at about half the time
it may not seem like much but when
you're running for a train that little
bit of time can make all the difference
the trouble is if everyone went the same
way i did there'd be a huge crush
there's not enough room
it would be slower for everyone the
tube's signage is a masterpiece of
design
the occasional lie makes it quicker
overall as a wise man once said the
needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few that's why
the london underground
lies to you
[Music]
you